is there something you could say about
the physical proximity and the chance
collisions
like we live in this time of the
pandemic where
everyone is maybe trying to see the
silver lining
and accepting the remote nature of
things
is is there one of the things that
people like faculty
that i talk to miss is the
the procrastination like the chance to
like everything is about meetings that
are supposed to be there's not a chance
to just
uh you know talk about comic book or
whatever like go into discussion that's
totally pointless
so it's funny you say this because
that's how we met matt
it's exactly that so i'll let michael
say that but i'll just add one thing
which is just that uh
you know research is a social process
and it helps to have
random social interactions even if they
don't feel social at the time that's how
you get things done
one of the great things about the a lab
when i was there i don't quite know what
it looks like now
once they've moved buildings but we had
entire walls that were whiteboards and
people would just get up there and they
were just right
and people would walk up and you'd have
arguments and you'd explain things to
one another and you got
so much out of the freedom to do that
you had to be
okay with people challenging every
freaking word you said which i would
sometimes find
deeply irritating but most of the time
it was it was quite useful but the sort
of pointlessness and the interaction was
in some sense the point at least for me
yeah i mean you i think
offline yesterday i mentioned josh
tannenbaum and he's very much
he put he's a man he's such an
inspiration in
in the child like way that he pulls you
in on any topic he doesn't even have to
be about machine learning it could
or or the the brain he'll just pull you
into a closest
writable surface which is uh still you
can find whiteboards at mit everywhere
and and just like uh like basically
cancel all meetings and talk for a
couple hours about some
some uh aimless thing and it it feels
like the whole world the time
space continuum kind of warps and that
becomes the most important thing
and then it's just it's so true it's
it's
definitely something worth missing in
this in this world where everything's
remote
there's some magic to the physical
presence whenever i wonder myself
whether mit really is as great as i
remember it i just go talk to josh yeah
you know that's funny is
there's a few people in this world that
carry the
the best of what particular institutions
stand for right and it's uh it's josh
i mean i i don't i my guess is he's
unaware of this
that's the point that the masters are
not
aware of their mastery
you